en 40 años esta pareja de jubilados
belgas nunca se ha cansado de esta vista
Pero sus binoculares pronto podrían ver
turbinas eólicas Francia planea instalar
un parque eólico frente a las costas de
dunkerque un proyecto que inquieta esta
pequeña ciudad costera belga situada
solo 2 km en línea recta de la frontera
francesa
tenemos una playa extraordinariamente
amplia con unas vistas magníficas que se
degradarían en cualquier caso con estos
aerogeneradores Bélgica solo tiene 60
kilómetros de Costa
frente a los casi 18.000 kilómetros de
litoral francés este proyecto irrita al
alcalde de la pana quien se reunió con
su homólogo francés en una ciudad al
otro lado de la frontera
los dos representantes electos comparten
preocupaciones comunes sobre el parque
eólico en particular su proximidad a la
costa Bélgica es pionera en el
desarrollo de esta energía verde y
construye sus parques eólicos más lejos
del litoral
en Bélgica ya hay un proyecto pero está
a 40 kilómetros del mar
si los franceses lo ponen a 10
kilómetros y los belgas a 40 por qué no
hacer un parque Franco belga a 30
kilómetros
y Francia está lejos de ser pionera
estamos más bien ocupados aprendiendo lo
que ocurre en otros países
Francia está rezagada en el sector de la
energía eólica y quiere ponerse al día
pero el proyecto frente a las costas de
dunquerque también preocupa a las
asociaciones ecologistas estaría situado
en una zona protegida por la que pasan
cada año muchas especies de aves
migratorias
este proyecto no tiene en cuenta ni por
un segundo las cuestiones de
biodiversidad cuando se tiene una zona
como ésta protegida para la migración y
aún así se autorizan aerogeneradores
significa que la protección sólo está en
el papel Eso es todo
las autoridades belgas han presentado
varios recursos judiciales contra el
proyecto al mismo tiempo se adelantan
conversaciones diplomáticas entre
Francia y Bélgica